[Music]
you claim you're not successful with
women is I think getting better now
here's my problem is I picked the wrong
women like I want to be in love but I'm
not ready for a relationship and the
caliber of women I'm picking is not good
like I'll give you don't date women who
come from money that's thick I'll give
you that advice build of scariest women
women world who come from women who make
their money and I'm talking about women
who come from like so much money cuz
there's no rules there's no consequences
their lives are a video game there's no
jail there's no like I'm sure they could
die and just spawn back at level one
like there's no it's terrifying like I
took a girl to dinner and we went to
this fancy place I couldn't afford it I
was working here and let me clarify this
though I did nothing here I was like the
owner's son like this was not we still
we should have given you something it
doesn't matter I couldn't afford this
place
we got a bottle of wine which I didn't
know was a thing she wanted it hearts in
the throat she drinks a little too much
you know
that's her issues we go outside to the
ballet and there's like a fancy foreign
car there we're waiting for mine and she
just goes hey let's take that car and
I'm like no no we shouldn't and she goes
wild be funny and I was like no will be
a felony and this is what she says to me
she goes you're no fun and I'm like who
are you dating
are you dating like Jason Bourne who are
you possibly take scars from a valet
yeah then we go to a bar and this is
this we go to a bar afterwards we're
drinking and I had to go to the bathroom
this is all I said there i sir I said
hey I'm sorry I have to go to the
bathroom this is what she does she goes
oh okay and then pulls out a baggie of
cocaine and hands it to me once again
all I said was hey I have to go to the
bathroom right I didn't say hey I have
to go to the bathroom do you have
cocaine I got never
came out and then she did the rich girl
thing like rich girls will just put it
on display like here you go oh she's not
even being no there's no discrete and
she's like mug shots a head shot like
she didn't care you know
like four girls at least had the decency
to go low like here take this I have a
son and a problem go you're not that I'm
hanging out with girls that do cocaine
all that watch undateable yeah yeah well
I'll mention I've read really nice
reviews for the show and I think in just
about every review I've read they've
singled out this gentleman for being
really fantastic in a future rising star
so hang in there pal you're doing great
thank you can tell you want your job
back you got it I might need it you will
not need it yes this kids going place we
have a clip here from undateable just
show the clipper dude yeah just show the
clip it's me talking to a girl I'm in
love with but not she's saying she's in
love with a friend but we don't really
know what's going on hopefully laughs
that's a lot of pressure let's take a
look Nikki can I talk to you about
something yeah of course okay there's
this this girl that I'm friends with and
I've been thinking about how I kind of
want it to be more than that that's um
really weird cuz um I've been thinking
about somebody - what was that so and I
am I think you might know him would you
describe this this this guy is handsome
um I would describe him as hot okay Wow
would you say that he's a very good
dancer
I would say he's actually a great dancer
oh well then he will be happy he spent
all that time as a kid training
[Applause]